i have not yet lost but i will
eventually lose i mean
probably you know any time now i'm
already over 2 000 so
eventually someone will come around who
catches a blunder or something like that
okay we're gonna go with another e4 game
[Music]
the openings are less important here
than the games themselves though
and now we're going to play lopez which
is my main opening that's sort of the
high level
defense
okay and he plays the berlin
now um there's many ways to play against
the berlin
but we're gonna go straight into it and
we're going to go into the end game
uh we're going to go into the berlin end
game because
i want to show you guys that it's not
just a draw it really okay he doesn't go
for the berlin
he does not go for the bull and he goes
d6 which is a very passive move but
that's like the stein it's defense
that's a
legitimate variation and previously
we'd been responding earlier by going c3
and d4 but now we're at a higher rating
let's play more topically let's play d4
immediately opening up the center why do
we open up the center because he's
played passively
so in order to exploit that we want to
maximally open things up
so that we can emphasize our advantage
in development
now the theory in this position is to
capture on c6 with the bishop keeping
our knight centralized
making a little defect defect in his
queen side pawn structure now here's the
thing
what do we want to do he wants to play
c5 to dislodge our knight
from the center right and it would be
very very nice if we could put our
knight on f5
but if we put our knight on f5 let's say
right now
then he will capture that knight and if
we capture with the pawn
uh that makes our king side pawn
structure bad
and it removes upon from the center b4
would be a little bit artificial
because that would weaken the night it
would weaken the pawn we don't actually
need to prevent c5 what we need to do
is we need to prepare the move knight f5
in response to it remember that
prophylaxis
can come from both directions you can
prevent the move itself but you can also
prepare a response against the move
and queen f3 is the best way to do that
because that is also conducive
to the general goals of the position you
simply bring a queen
a piece onto a better square and we can
continue to do that by bringing the
bishop in we don't have to go knight f5
yet
we we can only do that in response to c5
now we have a lot of pressure on his
position he goes knight g4
okay so
hmm let me think yeah so we can win a
pawn here
we have a cool way of winning upon who
sees it yeah so the knight on g4 what
jumps to mind for me
actually it doesn't win a pawn there's
ooh there's some really cool
complications
it actually does not win upon never mind
and i'll show you guys this after the
game
um scrap that scrap that i'll show you
guys why it doesn't win a pawn
but not right now because uh because our
time is ticking so let's take the bishop
and obviously this knight is super
annoying so let's kick it away let's go
h3
get out of here get out of here
now where should we move our queen in
the interest of
the fact that we are trying to attack
his king
where should we position our queen
what's sort of the typical square of the
typical squares of course g3
and potentially we can chase the knight
away with f4 although i would i i would
not play this move prematurely
okay so he's gone c5 in such situations
we always ask ourselves first and
foremost what squares
does a move like this leave behind
obviously knight f5 was what we
previously attended now it's not quite
as strong
but there is the move knight d5 and
noticing the queen and now we can go
knight f5
i previously said that it's not ideal
that we have a pawn that lands on f5 but
the situation has changed a little bit
now this pawn is actually an asset why
is it an asset because we can go f6
and combine with the queen let's apply
the same logic f6
what square does this weaken can we get
a piece to that square
tell me the maneuver exactly knight f4
and knight e6 very methodical
look at this juicy outpost on e6 with
the knight
his knight on e5 is not on an outpost we
can always chase it away by playing f4
we don't need to rush with that move
but when the time comes we can play that
move
f4 now why shouldn't we rush with that
move there's a deep logic behind this
what do we not want him to do what we
don't want him to do is to trade off
this knight
and the only way that he can trade off
this night is by using his own knight
okay so what we want to do dr along with
job is rookie one
we are anticipating that he's eventually
going to try to trade off the knights
and so we're adding some beef to that
knight
in preparation for that now we go rookie
for dual purpose move
number one we can double to lend more
supports than a number two we can rook
left that would be another
drawback of the move out four we would
prevent our own
ability to rook lift okay so he he loses
his patience decides to exchange
sacrifice
but the hesitation should tell you that
he's realized that he missed something
and that is the move f4
of course attacking the queen it's not
that simple he can move his queen away
and attack the knight but i saw that
this is also why we played rookie four
let's not forget the other purpose
what's the move what's the move
now we play the simple the simple darker
thank you for the sub
well queen e3 would violate the small
principle we talk about which is that
when you have a task that you can do
with one piece you should usually do it
with that piece rather than the queen
the queen should be
left at the sort of most important tasks
we double rooks and we get to e8 if he
moves his knight away
yeah backrank mate is not going to
happen
cleanly because he can get his knight to
f8 but he's going to be driven
very much to the back but let's not rush
and this is the importance of not
rushing
i a lot of people would immediately give
a check on ea but we need to spend a
couple seconds
in any position asking ourselves like is
there something better
is there something that maybe wins the
game in a slightly cleaner way and that
is the
rookie seven rookie also wins but he has
knight fa
and somehow he's holding on there i
could go rookie seven but what i want to
show
is that principle right you spent three
four five seconds nobody's died over
three four five seconds
and uh we find a move that ends the game
immediately because we have a fork
against uh the knight in the pawn and
the game is over
so he loses his knight he loses the game
very simple sort of straightforward
applying principles by the book and that
can produce some very effective chess
now let's do
piggies on the seventh
and um he goes richard so he continues
to play he's completely lost how do we
win
this position there are several
approaches
i think the most again if we're playing
this by the book the simplest approach
is to try to get a rook
on on this on the eighth rank
uh and in order to do that we finally
involve our queen we go queen e3 and
rookie a
that would be the most sort of you know
kind of like okay
it's not the best but it's the simplest
right we trade rooks
and when we trade rocks the win is going
to be super simple we don't need to take
immediately either
we can first help ourselves to a couple
pawns
that's going to lighten our load a
little bit i'm sure that there were
faster wins but
again part of the the in the speed run
i'm never playing
badly on purpose but sometimes i'm
playing uh differently than i would
normally play in order to
illustrate the range of ideas available
to us now instead of trading rooks
well we can actually just go rook c8
here that would be the simplest
we take he's actually kind of hanging on
here which is kind of funny
but we can give a check here and now
the simple idea would be to get a rook
to the sixth rank how can we get the
rook to e6
we want the rook to get to e6 how do we
do that
who can tell me rookie 8 and rookie 6 is
going to end the game one way or another
it's going to be either
checkmate or it's going to win the queen
rookie 6 queen h4 queen f7 is going to
be mate
and queen f7 here he's going to be a
pretty mate
we can even troll him a little bit if he
goes king h4
if he goes king h4 we control him by
taking on h6 or what's going to be the
actual checkmate
who can tell me what the mate is going
to be
let's see if i can ah let me let me do
some professional trolling
let me do some professional trolling i
was gonna go i was gonna sack my queen
i was gonna go here
and and then here but uh sadly he didn't
didn't allow us to
to do that um
i was gonna see if we have a way of
sacrificing both the rook and the queen
that would be pretty cool but no okay
let's look at the game
so the berlin is knight take c4
uh we won't delve into the theory here
god forbid
uh but uh the the berlin
the idea behind the berlin is is this
end game right you guys all probably
know
that this leads to the berlin end game
and at some point i might talk a little
bit about the berlin
game uh you know i might talk a little
bit about the berlin
game uh but
but not right now this is you know
extremely theoretical
so he goes d6 which is kind of um
which is kind of passive and d4 directly
follows the principle of opening up the
center when our opponent plays a little
bit passively
why is this move passive because well
because it
prevents his bishop from developing to
c5 which is the most active square this
is not a bad line i've played d6 myself
but it's a little bit um you know it it
it is
something that you have to play if you
know it very well because you can easily
slip into a
bad position which is essentially what
happens so take stakes
bishop d7 knight c3 developing bishop e7
uh bishop takes c6 which is the
theoretical move right
uh we are trading bishop for night
leaving our knight in the center
and forcing him to introduce a defect
into his spawn structure if he takes
with a bishop
we can take that bishop or we could
consider putting the knight on f5
straight away
so he takes to the pawn and we go queen
f3 now
when would you play c3 before d4 so we
could have played c3 even in this line
it's often a matter of taste here i
wanted to just illustrate a slightly
different way of playing
now um the idea behind queen f3 as i
explained during the game if we make
just any
random move he goes c5 and
we have to drop our knight back because
if we go knight f5
he takes on f5 and this is actually
quite unpleasant right we don't want to
get our pawn to f5
which is nicely blockaded by the knight
and can be easily attacked by the queen
and
our pawn on e4 was controlling the
center so now he has this an
kind of nasty idea well defense and pawn
structure actually don't matter that
much and that's something i've been
explaining throughout
uh it's just that the higher you get
right
the more and i explained this the last
time the more importance is assigned
to these small factors because small
factors
when taken together uh can decide the
game
and one of those small factors is
differences in pawn structure
while they don't usually decide the
outcome of the game in and of themselves
you you know you don't just want to make
free weaknesses if that makes sense
so queen f3 preparing to get the knight
to f5 so that we can capture with the
queen
okay he castles we go bishop g5 and he
goes knight g4 now here
a lot of you were wondering why i didn't
play knight takes c6
and the the point of this move is it's a
simple overloading tactic
the bishop on d7 is doing two things at
once it cannot
um accomplish them it's defending the
knight
and it was protecting the pawn so we
take the pawn overloading the bishop now
bishop takes c6
problem is we cannot take the knight
immediately because uh he
he plays bishop takes g5 and wins a
piece now we're also attacking the queen
here so if he takes immediately then we
win as queen
but it seems that white can simply take
the bishop on e7
and now i started thinking about
intermediate moves
and black is a desperado sacrifice the
knight is hanging he's going to lose it
anyway
so he might as well give it up for a
pawn but it's very important that this
move also attacks white's queen
so if we count up the pieces queen
knight bishop takes queen knight takes
queen
we get an equal pawn end game white's
got a ruined kingside pawn structure not
impressive
of course we can also take the knight
but then black takes the bishop and
black's bishop is super good here
it's pressuring the pawn black and
combine that with f5
so this moon knight takes h2 what did i
say about details defining games at this
level
that's what i mean now you might be
rated a thousand and hopefully i've
explained this in a way
where you should understand the
rationale behind this line right
it's not that it's impossible to
understand but calculating this in the
heat of a game can be difficult
really that's all there is to it it's
not that it's particularly complicated
now if you and if you take on e7 first
and i take c6 now
it's well it's actually different why is
knight takes h2 not the same thing who
can explain to me why this is not the
same thing
first of all and second of all for extra
credit what is black's move in this
position
similar concept knight takes queen comes
with check and even if it didn't this
square is undefended
so what should black do instead very
nasty little move what black can do here
is and
i'm not sure how bad this is but queen
h4 is what i didn't
like he's attacking mate
and threatening c6 it gets complicated i
decided not to go for that good job
so we played h3 chasing the knight away
reposition the queen on g3 where
x-rays the king c5 what is the drawback
of this move a high weakens d5 can we go
there immediately
no we can't knight is being attacked but
wait a second yes we can because it
attacks the queen
could we have gone knight f5 yes
absolutely not a bad move
takes takes but i was a little bit
worried about trading too many pieces
remember that when you're up in space
and when you're trying to attack
trades can lighten the load for your
opponent so
you know i just wasn't sure i didn't
think this was
a necessary thing to do immediately and
this would not have been bad
can you explain the decision to trade
dark square bishops well
uh you know i suppose we could have
dipped our bishop back
but i didn't want to let him activate
his bishop and put it on the long
diagonal
so this isn't something i'm like i love
to do but the alternative wastes more
time and it allows him to put his bishop
on a super good square
okay uh so anyways
so queen g3 c5 knight t5 and now we play
knight f5
and it's very important as i've
preached several times to use the method
of comparison
to understand the differences between
two different things compare them
don't try to understand each
individually that can be tough
comparison can yield tremendous levels
of instruction about
a set of ideas or a certain position
and specifically here i want you to
compare this position to this position
in both positions we've got this little
defect in our pawn structure three pawns
here and upon an f5 doubled
but there's one key difference as i
hinted at during the game
what is that difference
there's many differences of course but
um there's one difference that
makes this good for white well number
one the queen is more active that's
that's an ancillary phenomenon
but all of this is leading up to the
fact that the pawn is not blockaded
and it actually wants to go to f6 even
if he goes c6 we go f6 because we
threaten checkmate
forcing him to either create tremendous
weaknesses in his
kingside which sets up a potential
lobster pincermate or
create weaknesses in his king side like
this when we can basically coordinate
for a second away with the attack
so this one difference again small
differences
make the game go make the world go round
he plays f6 to blockade the pawn but now
he creates a massive weakness on e6
which we occupy immediately
now the move f4 very tempting
wrong because it actually helps him get
his knight to d8 and trade off our
knight
so what we do is we preemptively play
rookie one f4 is not going anywhere his
knight alone is not going to cause any
problems to us
right and um we're only going to go out
for when we are ready
to protect this knight in addition uh we
are preparing to
lift our rope why rookie wouldn't well
d1 orwell would not really
uh go about defending this night uh
you know he can move his queen away i
get that you wanted to pin the queen
but this rook is kind of lame and i
can't lift it because d4 square is
protected
absolutely why did i choose a rook and
not the f1
i'll put it this way guys i think in
this specific case both moves are
perfectly fine
but visually and i went by my intuition
here it just seemed a good idea
to keep another rook near my king for
whatever reason i wasn't exactly even
sure why
but i thought that maybe you know maybe
when i play f4 this rook will somehow
maneuver through f3 to g3
it's a minuscule difference i think this
was just as good
but there was something about that
particular concept that i liked that's
really all there is to it
i don't think it really matters here
it's it doesn't make a huge difference
in every case you shouldn't overthink it
uh so now we go rookie four as planned
and he loses his patience
now i already think he's basically lost
if he tries to get his knight around to
trade we can do two things we can lift
our rook up
and we can follow that up who can tell
me a very very powerful attacking idea
here white wins the game with a very
pretty tactical
sequence
queen g6 h6 and now we notice type 2 on
defended pieces
rook h7 i don't think quite does the
trick we notice that black's queen is
overloaded knight takes g7 overloading
very important rope takes h6 is a little
more complicated
i think you've got to be careful here i
don't see a follow-up here remember when
you only have two pieces in the attack
be super careful about sacrificing
keeping it simple
often pays a lot of dividends in the end
so he goes rookie six and now f4 either
wins the night
or uh allows us to infiltrate the back
two
ranks a rookie 8 would have also been
perfectly good
uh but we decided to play it very simple
and just win as night the rest is
the rest is very straightforward okay it
would take c7
broke cc8 forcing the trade on our terms
and that basically ends the game what if
he plays rook g8 where
oh at the end of that line well if he
plays rook g8 we just check made up on
h6 right once we take a pawn like this
we remove
the bottom jenga and the whole thing
collapses
any questions about this game i feel
like it was relatively simple
conceptually
and i want to show you guys one really
really instructive moment from one of my
games
that builds on a concept that we that we
talked about here
the concept that we talked about here is
the notion of supporting an outpost
right we had this outpost on e6 and our
opponent expressed the desire
to treat it by maneuvering migrating his
knight to d8
and that can actually change the game
whether or not we can retain a piece on
an outpost
can can really be the game-changing
phenomenon and so
one of the hardest things to do in chess
one of the things that you do
you learn to do when you become good is
to find creative ways
of maintaining a piece on a particular
square particularly maintaining a knight
on an outpost
and i had the chance to do that in a
game that i played a couple years ago
when i was in im and i believe that i
found a very very nice idea which i'd
like to show you guys
this game is from philadelphia open
2013. i made my second grandmaster norm
at this tournament and uh
the following position arose in round
two i am playing with the white pieces
my opponent 2100 in this position i
found
a very nice tactical idea i call this a
positional combination
because it's tactical in nature but the
goal is positional
it's like a tactical maneuver and
it's not that difficult to see if you
make the proper observations
for keeping that going so drum roll the
move is knight d4
and the idea is to get the knight to e6
and uh once the knight gets on e6
that's a beautiful outpost it's
protected by the pawn
now there's a couple of things that uh
that need to be explained about this but
philly boy 44.
some people notice that the move knight
h4
creates two threats knight takes f5 and
knight g6
problem with this move is that um
and let me actually remember what the
problem with this move is
uh knight's rule is actually not bad but
but there was something
i think i can play queen f7 and if you
take the pawn you expose
a very nasty little attack down the f
file black can move his knight away
and uh if white's knight moves then
queen takes f2 is going to be quite
unpleasant this is not bad
but it leads to some uh questionable
consequences
now the key question about knight d4
what makes this tactical
is the fact that you have to evaluate
knight takes d5 but what you guys have
to understand is that this
puts the knight and the king on the same
diagonal and the move bishop b3 is going
to be absolutely devastating
the knight is being attacked queen f7 is
the only defense
and now queen f3 is a simple move that
wins not only this night but also the
other night you're gonna win both nights
with the bishop
there it is now why is bishop e3
immediately bad
the reason is that in basketball you
know you can telegraph the pass
you know when you when you go like this
you know exactly
who who you're going to pass it to and
you signal to your opponent
hey i want to play knight t496 what's
the opponent going to do
bonus good no you're not oh you i'm
going to move my queen queen to d7
guess what the only reason that knight
d4 was possible
was because of the temporary phenomenon
of the pit
and that's something you have to exploit
immediately knight d4
does that make sense okay 2796
rook fe-8 now now he does threaten to
take on d5
because he's gonna chop the legs off of
the knife
so queen f3 is what i played
okay knight takes d5 i'm gonna take with
the bishop witho the queen now
he goes knight to d8 here's what the
battle revolves around
is he gonna be able to trade that knight
on e6 and obviously the answer is yes
there's nothing i can do about the trade
but what do i do
what do i do in this position in order
to make sure that that knight is going
to be
replaced by something even stronger
bishop3 is correct
queen takes f5 would be inferior on the
count of knight takes d5 and
the knight loses its support so i go
bishop b3
right and if he takes on e6 i take with
the pawn he has to move his queen
and look at this beaut on e6 it's not a
knight but it's the next best thing
okay uh and after rook a7 i play queen
takes f5
and he plays king h8 and in this
position i found the move
uh and the reason that i'm showing you
this game consists in this move
now what is my opponent threatening why
did he play king h8
the move that he played here is knight
takes the move that he intends is knight
takes d5
this is a simple undermining sacrifice
well not a sacrifice sorry tactic
you cannot take this knight because the
queen is pinned and if you play bishop
takes d5
then he plays knight 66 restoring
material equality and i know
and most importantly i no longer have an
outpost on e6
so i've really achieved very little here
uh well yeah dirty devin i'll mention
that later but
my question then is man i really want to
keep this knight on e6
you know i really i don't want to just
give it away and i can't take on d8
because the queen hangs
if you go knight takes g7 then he's just
gonna take on g7 with
the queen or the king by the way so what
the hell do we do
and in this position i was able to find
the kind of thing that i
described to you guys prophylaxis in a
tactical way
so nobody's seen the move yet actually
now let me tell you how was how i was
able to find the move this is hard guys
and g4 i would say is probably the
second best move although it's a little
weakening
now the way that i thought about it is
this let's imagine
and i call this the worst case scenario
test
when you're trying to find a
prophylactic move that is when you're
trying to find a way to stop your
opponent's threat
and it's not obvious how to stop it what
i suggest doing
is first assuming that your opponent
accomplishes that you let him do
whatever he wanted to do
all right you and i'll get to people's
suggestions in a moment
you let him do what he wants to do and
you think okay
let's fork let's broadcast to the final
position and let's look at this for a
second
what move could white potentially have
here
what would it be nice if white had in
this position
he can't make this move but what would
it be nice yeah bishop c6 wouldn't it be
nice
if you could play bishop c6 and bend the
queen to the rook
and i thought wait a second i can set
this up and so in the starting position
rook a to c1 is the move
and this move i was quite proud of this
is and i think you guys would agree with
me not only is this prophylactic
but it brings a piece into the game it's
a productive move
as a standalone move and it prevents
knight takes d5 he did this anyway
so i'll show you guys what happened in
the game but that's how i thought about
it
and that's the logic that i want you
guys to apply in many many different
cases i can give you another test
position
where that logic is applied directly
now some of you okay knight d4 is a very
interesting move but it fails tactically
because after ed
queen d7 rook d7 the knight defends the
rook on e8
now g4 i think is quite good and i
really like that people came up with
this
the idea being after knight takes d5
knight takes d the queen is protected
and so bishop takes d5 is going to
follow i love that mode g4 is probably
almost as good i would say that it's a
tiny bit weakening
on the king's side so maybe he can do
something like this and
you know he's still kicking because
because we've got some of these
weaknesses but i think g4 is also very
very good
rocket thank you for the sub queen h5
blunders the queen
and uh i think the other moves have you
know small tactical defects
queen f3 is also very good but i wanted
to keep my queen active
maybe here he plays knight f7 and tries
to get his knight to g5
so rookie c1 he took on d5
and then bishop c6 happened and now i
play the move queen e4 and d4
much like we did in that speed run game
the idea being
if knight takes d4 queen d4 because of
the pin he loses
so knight take rook takes c5 and he
resigned in this position
uh that basically was why i wanted to
show you this game
this idea of working backwards starting
from the final position
trying to set up an idea that could have
occurred in that final position
is uh is an interesting one and let me
show you guys one more
example of me doing that
and then we'll play one last game
so i had one other example that i can
remember
where i managed and i was quite proud of
doing this where i did something
similar okay
so this is my game from 2006
against an international master he was
also my first coach
okay so this guy was good it was a night
off yeah that's what i used to play
okay that's what i used to play
and um in this position
i was able to find what i think is a
really nice prophylactic idea now
in order to understand this what is the
purpose
of the move h4 what is my opponent's
next move going to be and i'm not asking
a trick question here
obvious question
i mean just go on no not no don't
overthink it
h4 what does he want h5
he wants to play h5 you know let's play
h5 and then he wants to play h6
i don't want to allow this i don't want
him to do this i also don't want to play
h6 because that creates a hook
which you can then use to play g5 using
the pawn as a battering ram
so i applied the same logic and i asked
myself okay wait a second let's imagine
that he plays h5 and let's try to detect
thank you wolf
what new weaknesses in his position are
created
well wait a second i thought this is a
type 2 undefended bishop
it's only protected by the queen that
seems like a vulnerable piece
could i try to preemptively set up a
tactic
against that bishop in the event of h5
thank you jose mvp with the rate of the
party of 51
really appreciate it hope you had a
great team welcome guys we're doing the
speed run
we're doing some lectures and you guys
are getting it
the move is queen to d8 i was really
proud of this move during the game
move his queen to d a now it's not
necessarily the best move according to
the computer
what is the idea the idea is if he goes
h5
then i play knight takes e4
and exposes the attack on the bishop if
bishop takes e7 this is a check
and if rook takes c4 then i play bishop
takes g5
and i win the pawn uh this would not
have been possible without the queen on
d8
because i would not have had enough
attacks on the bishop he would have
simply recaptured it
segfaulting for the prime appreciate it
now queen c5 would also do that with the
same idea
uh and i think queen c5 would have been
interesting but maybe here he goes
bishop e3
and he x-rays the queen in the game
he also played bishop b3 and i had time
to maneuver my queen
to maneuver my pieces i didn't have to
move my queen knight d7
f4 and back to f6 and i was able to slam
my knight in t but this is not a trick i
mean does this look like i'm going for
tricks
no this is i think this is pretty high
level prophylaxis
i'm actually trying to stop his ideas
and and i won the game
so i'm not saying this is the best uh
but i'm trying to give you guys an
example of this kind of backwards
thinking you assume
that your opponent accomplishes his
threat and then you try to detect
retroactively the drawbacks of that and
then you try to i
was meaning to say retroactively exploit
them in the starting position
clear okay let's move on i know that i'm
dragging on about this but hopefully
it's somewhat helpful
and let's uh
finish with uh one more one more speed
run game okay
at what age did you first beat a master
i think it was like probably 2004 maybe
eight or nine
[Music]
you